l'overdose de l'amérique george bush
lance un plan de bataille géant pour
lutter contre la drogue
mots clés la répression alain prost
pilotera pour ferrari c'est officiel il
a signé il réalise le rêve de tous les
pilotes de formule 1 bonsoir il est mort
dans la discrétion et pourtant c'était
l'un des plus grands écrivains de ce
siècle georges simenon avait 86 ans il a
été incinéré ce matin près de son
domicile de lausanne sa mort remonte à
lundi dernier il avait écrit plus de 500
livres et il est élu dans le monde
entier
il restera bien sûr le père du célèbre
commissaire maigret
isabelle staes notre envoyé spécial
s'est rendu à lausanne ce matin près du
lac léman perdu au milieu des tours une
petite maison dans les arbres
ici vivent et georges simenon il avait
dit un jour qu'il ne lui déplairait pas
de finir clochard avec sa compagne ils
menaient ici une existence austère seuls
quelques fleurs et télégramme ont
perturbé cet après-midi la vie du
quartier
discret simenon l'est resté jusqu'au
bout ses voisins n'ont appris la
nouvelle que ce matin j'ai toujours lu
surtout les maigret et puis quand on
s'est connus et installer ici je me suis
mise à lire d'autres france de lui et
j'ai lu beaucoup de ces nouvelles que
j'apprécie énormément
si la voix je ne le voyais pas la
fenêtre pardon oui dans son jardin
toujours très gentil très georges
simenon avait souhaité que sa mort ne
soit annoncé qu'après son enterrement
ce matin ses cendres ont été dispersées
sous le cèdre centenaire de son jardin
c'est là que reposent les cendres de sa
fille marie jo elle s'était suicidé à
l'âge de 25 ans à quoi mesure-t-on la
gloire d'un écrivain
si c'était à la quantité sinon serait
déjà un géant 500 livres au joli 10 500
millions d'exemplaires traduits dans
plus de 50 langues
mais ce que la littérature retiendra
c'est sans doute le regard juste qu'il
portait sur l'être humain
ces petites gens ordinaires dont il a
fait des héros syli marion rétrospective
je suis charmé penser à 20 joueurs mais
j'ai pensé avoir des lecteurs ce qui est
une chose tout à fait différent
maintenant encore par exemple je suis
heureux si je sais que ma gamme de
lecteurs va des mêmes lecteurs quel ceux
qui disaient les romans populaires jadis
elle conte professeur d'université c'est
parce qu'il avait six lecteurs là que
georges simenon a connu une gloire
inégalée tout le monde à lui lit ou lire
à l'un des 500 millions d'exemplaires de
ses romans vendus dans le monde
mais lorsqu'on disait qu'il était un cas
ils se mettaient très en colère tu pars
du toit cas et je rendais trac je ne
suis pas un cas c'est tout simplement
romancier c'est tout vous comprenez je
veux pas de disséquer sur une table de
demandes pour savoir pourquoi j'écris
161 roman est bien mais sans qu'elle
s'en soit encadrement met bout à bout ne
font pas plus que le dickens que leurs
devoirs père scott ou que l'oeuvre
deux dossiers c'est n'importe quelle
heure mais tout petit à côté d excuser
moi je ne compare pas mais ces gens-là
écrivait comme j'écris tout simplement
georges simenon était considéré par ses
contemporains les plus illustres andré
gide françois mauriac comme l'un des
grands écrivains de ce siècle
mais les maigret est écrit en dix jours
et les autres romans plus littéraire lui
ont rapporté des millions ils vivaient
en suisse une vie de château fastueuse
prenant ainsi sa revanche sur une
enfance pauvre marié deux fois
amateur de femmes avant et après ces
unions tumultueuse il connut le
désespoir lorsque sa fille marie jo se
suicida après sa mort il vécut temps
reclus auprès de sa femme du chambre
avec georges simenon disparaît en
littérature l'amour des petites gens des
quinze ans béret basque accoudé au
comptoir des zincs concierge en
charentaises montant l'escalier en bois
et l'odeur du petit caillou l'article
mougeotte au coin du feu
la fascination aussi les vilenies qu'on
dissimule derrière les volets clos des
grandes demeures bourgeoises georges
simenon un grand écrivain et l'image
d'une france qui s'enfuit l'oeuvre de
simenon est une mine inépuisable pour
les cinéastes carnet autant-lara
melville granier-deferre ou encore
tavernier jusqu'à patrice leconte dans
le film monsieur ir était présentée
encore à cannes cette année
mais sinon c'est surtout bien sûr le
commissaire maigret qui restera une des
figures majeures du cinéma et de la
télévision
amaigri on peut associer le 36 quai des
orfèvres le siège de la pj
et puis aussi on peut associer l'un de
ses interprètes les plus fameux jean
richard
entre reportages de rémy roche et d'orge
les goûts lui aussi il fume la pipe mais
c'est un vrai jean-pierre sanguy actuel
patron du 36 quai des orfèvres hommage
le vrai salue la mémoire de maigret le
faux en soulignant ses qualités de
modèles la valeur d'exemple de maigret
personnage ça a été la profondeur du
personnage son équilibre professionnel
sa façon de travailler en artisan sans
haine mais sans pitié sans illusion mais
avec la volonté d'aboutir et la
constance d'aboutir cette image
c'était l'image en fait de lettres
humaines dans la police
sans défaut presse qu'il était parfait
mais gré nous ne sont pas parfaits c'est
pour ça que je suis persuadé qu'à une
certaine époque
des policiers ont voulu ressembler à
migrer morphologiquement ce qui est plus
difficile psychologiquement mais ça a
été un facteur d'équilibré je pense dans
toujours cette enquête qui est très
spéciale qu'ils enquêtent rennes à mon
avis de l'omission du crime de sang qui
demande une rigueur
j'allais dire parfaite le personnage de
maigret arriva d'éthane sur vous je
deviens un peu maigret dans la vie et
maintenant ceci dit peut-être que si
mais non lui-même mais je crois que si
mines on a voulu que son minerai soit
sympathique parce que je crois et je
l'écris
je crois que c'est le personnage que lui
chimie nous on reste maîtres perdent un
temps des ce qui nous donne des des
conseils pour l'interprétation du
maigret il m'a simplement du valais il a
dit des points quand le commissaire
maigret sort de chez lui le matin qu'il
va à son bureau
comment des dealers revoir madame migré
il embrasse huer de jouer très important
petite claque sur les fesses
ce soir antenne 2 consacre toute la
soirée à rendre hommage à sa georges
simenon avec la diffusion de ce maigre
et très célèbre la tête d'un homme c'est
d'ailleurs l'épisode préférés de jean
richard il nous l'a dit tout à l'heure
dans le journal de 13 heures et puis
ensuite il y aura la rediffusion da
postroff qui lui avait été consacrée en
1981 nous reviendrons sur tout cela à la
fin de cette édition justement avec
bernard pivot
mais d'ailleurs tout au long de ce
journal vous l'avez peut-être déjà
remarqué nous rendons nous aussi un
hommage discret à sydney le reste de
l'actualité en effet avec d'abord du
luxe pas cher le prix des automobiles va
diminuer le conseil des ministres ont en
effet décidé tout à l'heure un 6 une
baisse de la tva sur les voitures de 28
à 25 %
l'idée c'est d'harmoniser notre
fiscalité avec les autres pays européens
car chazal si vous attendez après demain
pour acheter votre voiture vous la paire
est moins chère de 2,3 pour cent la tva
sur l'automobile baisse pour la seconde
fois en deux ans elle passe de 28 à 25 %
coût pour l'état près de 6 milliards de
francs mais le ministre des finances
peut aussi se réjouir
l'inflation se radoucit cette année
d'environ 0,2 point et dépassera à peine
3%
les constructeurs français ont eux aussi
sont plutôt satisfaits attirés par des
prix plus bas
leurs clients devraient se bousculer
chez les concessionnaires mais revers de
la médaille renault ou peugeot sont
actuellement en pleine surchauffe et
arrive à peine à satisfaire la demande
ils redoutent donc une ruée sur les
étrangères et l'on peut craindre un
surcroît d'importation mais les mesures
prises par ailleurs par le gouvernement
pour aligner les sociétés de leasing sur
les conditions normales de déduction de
la tva devrait pénaliser ceux qui
choisissent la location gérance
autrement dit les acheteurs de grosses
cylindrées souvent allemandes anglaises
ou américaines
autre décision du conseil des ministres
un projet de loi pour régler les
difficultés liées à l'endettement
excessif des ménages pour acheter
maisons et voitures on prend des crédits
et puis un jour trop c'est trop on ne
peut plus payer
c'est pourquoi une loi de conciliation
va être mise en place
elisabeth est venu imaginer qu'avec onze
mille francs de revenus par mois une
famille totalisent 8 1600 francs de
remboursement de créer
comment en est elle arrivée là il y a
plusieurs cas de figure ou bien elle
s'est volontairement laissé tenter par
la possibilité du tout tout de suite ou
bien les professionnels n'ont pas été
assez précis avec elle lors des
signatures de contrats promoteurs
immobiliers banques organismes de crédit
brandissent parfois le miroir aux
alouettes pour allécher au plus vite le
consommateur et on est dans un
environnement où tout va très vite nous
octroyons les crédits générés presqu'à
la chaîne est en général nous ne
disposons pas d'une information qui tout
à fait essentiel qui est lent bêtement
de nos clients au départ nous ne
connaissons pas si un fichier national
des incidents de paiement est mis en
place
la situation sera plus claire quant aux
créanciers malgré tout en difficulté il
pourra s'adresser à la commission de
conciliation de son département pour
tenter un règlement à l'amiable
s'il n'aboutit pas dernier recours le
juge qui pourra échelonner les paiements
ou réduire les taux d'intérêt
des mesures qui ne font pas l'unanimité
chez les consommateurs pour lui le fait
que choisir la montagne a accouché d'une
souris
d'abord la saisine de la commission de
conciliation n'empêchera pas les
créanciers de continuer à poursuivre le
débiteur deuxième chose le pouvoir du
juge sont très limités quant aux
banquiers ils parlent de discrimination
puisque les créances publiques impôts ou
facturé df resteront recouvrables en
priorité puis enfin retenir encore de ce
conseil des ministres décidément très
chargé le rappel à l'ordre de michel
rocard il a tapé du poing sur la table
pour rappeler les principes de
solidarité gouvernementale
alors gilles leclair pourquoi le premier
ministre at il ainsi aux states en tout
d'un coup là c'est la rentrée y compris
pour les ministres du gouvernement et
c'est toujours le moment vous le savez
où l'on prend de bonnes résolutions
c'est ce que michel rocard a voulu faire
cela nellement ce matin au conseil des
ministres
appuyée du reste par françois mitterrand
en fait le premier ministre a surtout
voulu prendre les devants c'est vrai
qu'il y avait déjà eu quelques couacs
ces dernières semaines à propos du
budget du malaise au sein de la
gendarmerie
le plus récent étant même la polémique
lionel jospin paul quilès sur l'avenir
des ptt
des escarmouches sans grande gravité
mais qui aurait pu ne dérape et michel
rocard ne souhaite pas en effet mélanger
les gens débat interne au ps dit-il
al'approche du congrès pourquoi pas
débat public au sein du gouvernement
là pas question c'est un rappel à
l'ordre ferme
de la part du premier ministre qui sait
que cette rentrée rentrée sociale
rentrée parlementaire ne sera pas
obligatoirement faciles pour lui et
qu'il n'a pas besoin d'avoir en plus des
soucis supplémentaires donc avec ses
propres
m un moyen aussi de rappeler qu'il ya
bien un patron à la tête de ce
gouvernement ce n'est pas inutile de le
rappeler aux besoins en dramatisant un
peu les choses c'est de la politique
merci gilles la sphère de la société
générale suite le procureur du tribunal
de paris a ordonné une enquête
préliminaire
cette enquête a été confiée à la brigade
financière et elle fait suite au rapport
de la coop qui vous en souvenez parler
de délit d'initié pour cette affaire de
la société générale et au chapitre
économique j'ajoute encore cette grève à
l'usiné peugeot de mulhouse ce matin
plusieurs centaines de grévistes ont
occupé un carrefour autoroutier à
l'entrée de la ville la circulation
étaient ainsi bloqués sur l'autoroute
a36 la guerre contre la drogue aux
etats-unis c'est l'overdose à washington
et le président george bush a annoncé
comme prévu un véritable plan de
bataille pour lutter contre ce fléau
l'action du gouvernement américain va
s'articuler autour de trois axes d'abord
l'aide internationale au pays du bien la
drogue et qui veulent lutter contre
cette trafic concept ray contre ce
trafic de drogue j'y arriverai
deuxièmement la prévention aux états
unis dans les écoles et les universités
par exemple et puis troisièmement
surtout la répression il s'agit de punir
plus les trafiquants mais aussi les
toxicomanes xhaka bouchard à washington
c'est l'image que l'on retrouve à la une
de toute la presse américaine george
bush je vous présente un sac en
plastique rempli de cocaïne a été saisie
aux abords de la maison blanche c'est du
poison pas des friandises
s'exclame le président george bush a
frappé les imaginations mais at il
convaincu
à la première heure ce matin william
bennett surnommé le tsar anti drogue a
fait le siège des élus du congrès pour
obtenir leur soutien à l'offensive
présidentielle
car les démocrates se montrent
sceptiques joe biden l'un de leurs
leaders juge insuffisants les forfaits
pour le traitement des toxicomanes selon
les douanes kennedy il faudrait rogner
sur les dépenses militaires ou accepter
une augmentation des impôts pour gagner
véritablement la guerre de la drogue
george bush a mis le doigt sur l'un des
aspects les plus douloureux de la
toxicomanie en visitant ce matin une
maternité où naissent des bébés de mère
droguée il y en a cent mille chaque
année aux états unis
l'une des priorités du président est de
renforcer la prévention l'éducation à
l'école lycées et universités devront
mettre en place des programmes anti
drogue pour bénéficier des subventions
fédérales
par dessus tout la maison blanche entend
se doter des armes les plus efficaces
pour enrayer le flot de stupéfiants qui
inondent le marché américain
malgré des saisies de plus en plus
massive à cet égard la bataille
déclenché en colombie aurais tu as
premiers résultats encourageants selon
les douanes californienne les arrivages
de cocaïne sont au plus bas depuis une
semaine avec pour conséquence une
envolée des prix qui serait passée de 70
milles à 140 milles francs le kilo à la
frontière pendant ce temps là en
colombie les troubles continuent les
pouces et le chauffeur
la responsable de la police colombienne
ont été assassinés les auteurs de
l'attentât appartiendrait à cette mafia
de la drogue et l'annoncé du plan anti
drogue de george bush a été saluée en
colombie par une série d'attentats
bruno alba notre envoyé spécial
il était 11h30 les tueurs attendaient à
la sortie d'un supermarché dans la fox
maghen les pouces d'un officier
colombien une jeune femme de 30 ans elle
venait de faire ses courses deux hommes
en embuscade rendrait la mort 1 a été
tué sur le coup
son mari un colonel n'occupe aucune
fonction liées à la lutte contre les
trafiquants il est chargé de questions
administratives
l'attentât n'a pas été revendiqué 3
davantage celui de medellin
hier soir ils deux journalistes
américains ont été blessés dans un
restaurant à la mode par l'explosion
d'une bombe
on trouve tout cela la une des journaux
de bogota en bonne place à côté des
articles consacrés au discours du
président bush alors qu'il est aucune
réaction officielle n'a encore été
enregistré les colombiens en général
sont assez satisfait de l'engagement
américain et le ton de la presse de volx
gotha n'est pas particulièrement
enthousiaste d'une éditorialistes va
même jusqu'à se demander où se trouve la
solidarité internationale bien sûr
écrit-elle l'aide américaine arrive en
colombie mais cette aide a un effet
pervers il ne fait que renforcer la
dépendance de notre pays vis-à-vis des
etats-unis d'amérique et cette
journaliste ajoute qu'en est-il de
l'inertie de l'europe
sans doute une manière de demander aux
12 d'aller un peu plus au delà des
déclarations d'intention et à propos de
drogue cette saisie spectaculaire à hong
kong c'est même la plus grosse prise de
drogue le record du monde si vous voulez
de l'héroïne pure saisit donc à hong
kong pour une valeur de 2 milliards 800
millions de francs
c'est à dire 280 milliards de centimes
si vous préférez la quantité saisie
serait suffisante paraît-il pour
approvisionner 20% du marché américain
pendant un an en afrique du sud il
s'agit bien d'élections blanche au sens
propre du terme puisque seuls les blancs
un sud africain sur quatre ont le droit
de voter
les noirs pendant ce temps là font la
grève mais les élections n'ont pas donné
lieu pour l'instant à des incidents
martine laroche joubert
notre envoyé spécial
nous allons avoir un bon résultat mais
je ne peux pas faire de prédictions
demain vous allez célébrer votre dieu
toi oui définitivement
combien de sièges penser au coût que
l'extrême droite de parti conservateur
eh bien j'ai écrit le chiffre sur une
enveloppe sur une feuille que j'ai mis
dans une enveloppe
lorsque je vais la retirer je vais là à
comparer avec mes résultats mais pas
avant demain je vous dirai si je me suis
trompé ou pas à votre avis quel est le
message des électeurs
d'abord un message politique une
nouvelle forme et puis pour un programme
imaginatif il soutient un candidat du
parti national pour eux un homme voit ce
n'est pas pour demain
si on a eu un homme un brin de voix
partout en afrique on est venu à la
tyrannie on veut pas avoir la même chose
ici il ya un échange les aspirations et
les peurs des deux côtés et nous croyons
avec une grande coalition de race ici on
pourrait avoir une fédération qui
marchera machaallah façon africaine est
ce que vous voyez travaillons par
exemple à côté d'un ministre noir un
match très long c'est tout à fait
possible dans un futur sud-africain côté
noir les teintes type assez calme
aujourd'hui
pour eux ces élections dont ils sont
exclus ne leur offre pas l'espoir d'un
changement
ce qu'il ya de certain c'est que la
campagne de défense organisée par les
mouvements qui apartheid a bien
fonctionné fille à soweto la très grande
majorité des noirs n'est pas aller
travailler
une protestation au pacifique pour le
moment la sphère du carmel d'auschwitz
continue d'empoisonner les rapports
entre juifs et chrétiens l'église
polonaise je vous le rappelle ne veut
pas déplacés le couvent contrairement à
ce qui avait été prévu par un accord en
87 dans son émission du côté de chez
fred demain après midi à 15h 15 frédéric
mitterrand recevra le prix nobel de la
paix elie wiesel qui publie un nouveau
livre et monseigneur lustiger
l'archevêque de paris et bien voici un
extrait de leur dialogue
on ne peut pas traiter ça comme on
traite un arbitrage à propos d'une garde
frontières ou de entre entre deux pays
entre deux riverains qui se disputent
quelques mètres carrés de terrain c'est
l'enjeu est beaucoup plus grave et on ne
peut le résoudre
au fond que si on fait face au problème
du mal et au problème du mal non
seulement dans le passé mais aujourd'hui
car cette plaie purulente elle continue
à coeur dans le monde et la deuxième
remarque c'est que au fond si nous ne
voyons pas la véritable dimension
spirituelle de cette affaire c'est
hitler qui regagnaient je suis d'accord
sur le deuxième point n'est pas sur le
premier dit ne sais pas c'est le mal
c'est en même temps élever le débat et
le réduire à une sorte d'abstraction
malheureusement de silence de pie xii
est maintenant succédé par le silence
jean paul ii donc ce n'est pas
simplement une question de mal ou
d'attitude est le mal mais j'attends
autre chose
j'aimerais en tout cas que le pape jean
paul 2 interviennent c'est sa parole
seul qui qui qui pourrait trancher
il faut qu'ils disent ça suffit
que s'est il passé en irak à la mi-août
une explosion dans une usine d'armement
aurait fait de très nombreuses victimes
il y aurait 700 morts et de très
nombreux blessés brûlés par des armes
chimiques semble-t-il
voyons maintenant d'autres informations
internationales à commencer par la libye
et quelques nouveaux délires du colonel
kadhafi les juifs doivent quitter la
palestine repartir en europe et chercher
asile en alsace lorraine et propos du
colonel kadhafi à la tribune du sommet
des pays non alignés à belgrade
explications pour le numéro un libyen la
logique est simple juifs doivent évacuer
la palestine leur transfert en alsace
lorraine permettra à la france de régler
son contentieux avec l'allemagne autre
avantage toujours selon le colonel
kadhafi la création de cette entité
facilitera les migrations des juges urss
ailleurs que vers le monde arabe
raccourcis historiques propos
provocateurs dans la salle la surprise
et quelques sourires
évacuation de l'ambassade américaine à
beyrouth en quelques heures
l'ambassadeur john mccarthy et 29
diplomates ont été embarqués à bord
d'hélicoptères direction chypre une
évacuation mener comme une véritable
opération commando
et pour raisons de sécurité que
l'ambassade a été fermée à washington le
département d'état a fait savoir ce soir
que l'ambassade fonctionnait de nouveau
dès que les conditions le permettront
pas de problème à bord tout fonctionne
normalement ce matin soyouz tma-18 a
décollé de la station de baïkonour en
asie centrale soviétique
à bord deux cosmonautes alexandre victor
enhco et alexandre serebrov les deux
hommes atteindront vendredi la station
orbitale mir inoccupé depuis le 27 avril
dernier en raison de problèmes
techniques et budgétaires
les responsables soviétiques ont décidé
de reprendre les vols habités
les deux cosmonautes resteront six mois
à bord de mire
qui a tout cela j'ajoute les pilotes
d'un drame dont je vous parlais hier la
disparition d'un boeing brésilien en
pleine forêt amazonienne et bien l'avion
ont été retrouvés le pilote a réussi à
poser cet avion en pleine jungle
il y a tout de même 13 morts mais 41
survivants dans le pilote mais ce pilote
aurait une grosse responsabilité dans
l'accident
parce que paraît-il il écoutait à la
radio au lieu de piloter le match de
football brésil chili
les ennuis de danièle gilbert la
présentatrice est en garde à vue elle et
elle pourrait même être inculpé ce soir
elle vantait vous en souvenez peut-être
les mérites d'une bague miraculeuse dans
la presse c'était une escroquerie
hervé brusini et oui c'est bien ce
sourire là qui vantait les bienfaits
d'une petite bague magique portela 30
jours disait daniel dans la publicité et
il vous arrivera un événement heureux
par mademoiselle gilbert cela risque
d'être la pression car à grasse des
milliers d'acheteurs ont porté plainte
on devait les rembourser s'il n'était
pas satisfait bien sûr les
remboursements il l'attend encore
et daniel gilbert d'être inculpé pour
une escroquerie dont le montant
s'élèverait à 80 millions de francs
les gérants de la société qui vendait
les bac par correspondance ont été eux
aussi interpellés ce soir face au juge
d'instruction la vedette de télévision
devra user de tout son charme pour sa
défense
le magistrat est parait-il coriace dans
ce genre de dossier quand les stars du
sport français et refont parler d'elles
yannick noah ce soir jouent une place en
demi finale de l'us open en quarts de
finale il rend compte en effet boris
becker ça se passe cette nuit à new york
alain prost lui vient de signer un
contrat à l'italienne
le rêve de tous les pilotes entrés chez
ferrari c'est officiel alain prost est
expliquée à lionel chamoulaud tout à
l'heure chez ferrari je crois que à ses
toutous réunis
fait que ferrari bien entendu l'équipe
plus prestigieuses le fait qu'on peut
pas s'endormir chez ferrari
mais uniquement l'enthousiasmé des les
italiens les tifosi c'est que vous
pouvez pas vous endormir et vous êtes
obligés d'être tout le temps motivé fait
qu'il ya un challenge aussi techniques à
surmonter
je crois que je peux être très très très
très heureux pendant moins dans tout cas
en tout cas chez eux alors dit aussi que
c'est peut-être même sûrement le contrat
du siècle ce qui concerne les mois la
formule 1 ça a joué aussi certainement
je crois que aussi bien les gentils
renault que williams et si certains
sponsors était et est enclin à me
rémunérer encore plus que ferrari elle
j'ai plutôt choisi ferrari pour le pour
autre chose que pour l'argent après tout
c'est aussi d'enthousiasmé que ça va
soulever en italie depuis le temps qu'il
vous attendent
exactement ça fait bizarre maintenant
j'ai vu des premiers contacts avec
serrar et ça n'a pas pu se faire
certains moments parce que j'étais en
contre à d'autres moments parce que je
crois j'ai pas confiance et était bien
entendu plus tenté par mclaren ou de
rester chez mclaren
deux années plus uniquement pour une
question de
compétitivité mais à l'heure actuelle
pas que c'est le bon moment le bon choix
au bon moment que j'ai fait parce que ça
veut dire que en signant pour ferrari
aujourd'hui vous ne serez pas champion
du monde cette année
ça c'est un point d'interrogation
ap alger pas absolument pas répondre à
cette question je sais pas star encore
avec diego maradona c'est une histoire
qui se termine cette fois en eau de
boudin
le joueur de naples a dit qu'il allait
jouer à naples tout simplement cette
année point final donc au feuilleton de
l'été
et pour terminer cette édition comme
promis un nouvel hommage à simenon dont
on a appris la mort ce matin hommage
d'un autre écrivain jean vautrin qui
connaît bien le monde de simenon avec
michel sur le vix ci se sont rendus sur
quelques lieux encore hanté par la
présence du commissaire maigret
reportage est bien ici c'est un endroit
complètement stratégique
je dirais que c'est presque le cimetière
des éléphants ici parce que on est en
train de vivre à côté d'une époque qui
est en train de mourir
on voit là bas les derniers pêcheurs on
va passer les derniers bateaux on va les
derniers parisien est heureux quand on
est dans ce café on s'attend à voir
entrer maigret on serait pas surpris du
tout le voir venir s'asseoir ici prendra
calvados être enrhume éventuellement
penser à madame mégret qui lui interdit
de boire trop vieux trop d'alcool et
puis commencer à parler avec la dame là
bas où la demoiselle et puis chercher à
piocher sont amenés à entrer en elle
pour parce que quelqu'un a été tué dans
le quartier alors maigret plus qu'un
juge puisse qu'elle est active devient
une espèce de médecin des âmes comme ça
qui va s'installer dans les dents les
personnes qui va apprendre aller
conquérir à débarquer sur leur plage
secrète et puis a rassemblé tout ça et à
se faire une idée psychologique delà de
la fibre profonde de la personne et
savait que ses petits
ces petites brindilles comme ça que
petit à petit le policier arrive à se
faire une idée un diagnostic du crime
c'est une manière en sommes très très
humaine et humaniste place de pratiquer
la police je vous rappelle donc la
soirée hommage sur antenne 2 d'abord
aussitôt après cette édition du journal
et après la météo vous aurez la
diffusion de l'un des plus célèbres
maigret la tête d'un homme est aussitôt
après cette rediffusion
une rediffusion d' apostrophes de 1981
que bernard pivot donc avait consacré à
simenon bernard pivot j'imagine que
c'est un grand souvenir pour vous
évidemment un grand souvenir à tête à
tête avec georges simenon pendant une
heure et quart dans sa petite maison de
la banlieue de lausanne c'est un très
très grand souvenir alors il faut dire
que cet entretien avait été réalisée par
ce que simenon venait de publier son
dernier livre c'était ses mémoires
intimes et il avait écrit cet ouvrage on
peut scriptum a servi parce que sa fille
chérie marie jo s'était suicidé quelques
mois auparavant
et dans cet ouvrage qui est poignant il
s'il avait voulu se raconte et se mettra
à nu il avait voulu se justifier
s'expliquer et même dialoguer au delà de
la mort avec marie-jo alors de tous les
entretiens que de grands écrivains m'ont
accordé c'est évidemment le plus
impudique le plus impudique parce que
simenon avait décidé ce jour là de dire
peut-être pas toute la vérité en tout
cas une grande part de sa vérité et puis
évidemment mon rôle c'était de lui poser
des questions un peu un peu indiscrètes
ce qui fait que ce cet entretien et
souvent émouvant et parfois même très
dérangeant mais jean simon avait dit
ceci ce sera mon dernier entretien et je
préfère qu'on me détestent pour ce que
je suis plutôt qu'on m'aime pour ce que
je ne suis pas une phrase terrible
merci bernard pivot donc ce sera tout à
l'heure vers 22h05 je crois aussi tôt
après la rediffusion du maigret et puis
ensuite dernière édition du journal en
reste alliés il vous le présentera vers
23h15 mais tout de suite bien sûr vous
avez rendez vous avec laurent cabrol
pour les prévisions de la météo
voilà fin de ce journal à demain 20
heures